Howard
it's the White House Howard hunt Howard
the president asked for a real son of a
[__] to handle this Pentagon leak what
do you need I want you to meet Gordon
Liddy toughest guy I know to hold his
hand in the flame of the candle I do not
Bend and I do not break what's the trick
there's a one gets third degree burns
every time please stop
you now work for the committee to
re-elect the president
your new mission is to make sure he wins
this election will intercept
confidential information of the radical
left
what's the plan we're going to hit the
DNC Watergate Howard that is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard
[Music]
strike tonight
these are the wrong doors what he has
the wrong tools
[Music]
and we walk straight in the front door
vault
somebody needs to clean this mess up you
want us to break in a fourth time wait
what do you mean a fourth time
nothing spy talk
how does it work there's a chance I'd be
going to prison
wait what
I really hope you understand the scope
and scale of this thing you tell the
spineless Too Faced politicians loyalty
is a two-way street
[Applause]
[Music]
should you just use the fun family
outing to cover up some spy fish
a bunch of bulls why are you shredding
money with Patriots acting in the
country's best interests
what about the best interest of your
family
[Music]
they are trying to break us
president is a good man
between you and me I worry about some of
the people with whom he surrounds
himself
[Music]
plumbers we fix leukes
there is reason they wanted me why me
Charlotte but they're all worse Fates
than marrying the king of England
[Music]
it is time we were United as a society
you will make lots of babies as many
babies as possible for my son
[Music]
my life as Queen was difficult
and Grimsley I'm always with you
highness
Grimsley tell me about the king is he
ugly perhaps deformed he is the king yes
and
hello my lady are you in need of
assistance if you must know I'm trying
to climb Over the Garden Wall whatever
four you refuse to help a lady in
distrust I refuse when she's trying to
go over a wall so that she does not have
to marry me
hello Sean
your majesty
to you I'm George
[Music]
I realize you have no reason to like me
but if you will give me one evening of
your time it might make you hate me a
little bit less that's a reasonable idea
put this one into place
your majesty and Lady Gaga interview on
your court and we shall be great friends
be careful you are the first of your
kind you must secure your position
where is The King The King cannot see
you now Charlotte may require privacy
Jesus wife she should know there is
nothing to know
I need to know what is going on at
Buckingham house your marriage cannot go
wrong
what's happening I do not want to fight
I
I fight for me
the Majesty your focus should be your
country
you are our Queen
[Music]
not breathtaking brick rules caught
Scandal and the most Royal person I've
ever known it is you and me together
[Music]
love can Bloom from the fullness of
gardens your flower metaphors make me
nauseated with their sweetness but I
applaud your point
[Music]
hey would you be mad if I went somewhere
anti-gay for my honeymoon uh hello sweet
sister
this week in gay news the Indie drama
Night Nurse is finally set to Premiere
three years later after the most cover
delays of any movie I had so much fun
shooting this and was it exactly what
you thought it would be
everyone outside now there has been a
positive yeah yeah it was uh very fun
you've been killing it these last couple
years how old are you these days I'm 18.
oh my God [__] me no almost 18. it's in
a few days oh good to see you cutie this
[__] industry
Brooke's still killing it as a manager
you represent Pat dubeck and Chase
streams also a drape disasters with
Maria Menounos rookie we have a lot of
good programming yes I am proud to be a
part of all these vital shows
what we both do is nothing what we do is
don't you want acting to be more I'd
love to not just act but also to make a
difference so I want to be gay Albert
Einstein and win an Oscar
[Music]
being a manager meaningful to me but I
can't do it without feeling judged okay
this sort of feels like a therapy
situation
[Music]
we're nothing like your kids neither of
us know a thing about the entertainment
industry
everything in my life can be insane but
not me and them so you are alive we need
to be normal and if we're normal then I
can handle the rest
okay what the hell in your face Brooke
hey hey Mom you can't say this [__]
about your base god you're worse on
social media than Carrie take that back
hey now we're all on the same team here
okay you're right I'm sorry that was too
far
parents are asleep in the next round so
we for real can't have sex cause my my
hole is out
oh
how long will you be staying I don't
know where are you staying no idea any
drugs or alcohol no
[Music]
unanimous
wanted to spend a little time with my
grandson that's what it's all about
you're not supposed to smoke here
what are you a forest ranger
Peter mom does Dave know you have his
Klingon sword it's a glave and no he
doesn't
you run around like a kid and you're not
a kid anymore you're a man ow you know I
think I turned out okay right oh you
live with your mom and she lives with me
okay but I pay the mortgage
you run away from people who love you
nothing is as important as family do you
know what it's like how people
constantly ask you about your brother
I Googled myself yesterday
oh it was bad
[Music]
lead a quiet life
no I try to do nice things yeah they
still think I'm like a joke
[Music]
I just want like a regular type butt
we're in comedy you gotta be able to
walk away from anything in your life in
30 seconds flat that's why I got nothing
tying me down
you're a kid oh yeah
[Music]
we do not know why we are here
we do not know who built the silent
and why we are underground
we only know
the world outside our Sanctuary is death
boil The Pact down to one room
do not say you want to go outside
or you will go outside
don't you ever think about the world
Beyond The Silo what we see is not
what's out there
got a mechanical there's always someone
who has a theory about this I know
to find out the truth
I found something that might hold the
answers to a lot of questions
and keep your head down
are you willing to give everything you
have for this
[Music]
clock is running there's not much time
left
this is a threat to order in the silence
I don't care about ordering what about
the truth
[Music]
some Mysteries
they're best left unsolved
[Music]
ever thought of joining the FBI no
I haven't
looking for people outside of law
enforcement
as a student of the FBI
[Music]
truth
and knowledge I worked in Insurance
before applying to the bureau I was a
nurse
you don't know me no but
oh well
I've had good classes but I never had
an exceptional one
so glad we're in the same class Soma
I'm going to look after one another
[Applause]
[Music]
toast class of 09 classical
The Bureau claims to want different
types of people
so long as we all do the same thing
open up
open up I've overseen changes to the way
the bureau operates we don't spy on our
own we saw because we have to
it's not your job to protect me from the
world that's my only job I can try and
make this right
no matter how hard we try
we always reveal ourselves
[Music]
they're watching you
good luck
[Music]
there are no secrets in the city of New
York there's cameras everywhere phone
records parking tickets
someone saw something heard something
City always knows
Sam got shot in Central Park
we're like basically best friends
we're gonna find who did this story
figure out who the connection is
Samantha is
[Music]
we figure out who shot was
uh
[Music]
police detectives were here
where were you on July 4th
I don't know how I don't know why
but this girl was connected to us
you guys know Sam you might know why she
left me I got shot Sam was one of us
whatever Sam knew I want to know too
[Music]
who left me clues she was on to
something I think I'm the only one that
can figure this out we gotta learn more
about these people
the generations you're hiding something
when we started this revolution we knew
it would have a cost
not the only one with secrets
[Music]
we've had some difficulties apparently
marriage has challenges there was some
Bloodshed she tried to kill me I did
well that shakes a man how can we trust
each other Faith annoying answer agreed
all hail Catherine the Great
empress and I are at peace in truth in
love I may have some relation anchor at
times understood I'm no longer the child
bride who took this place but I will be
the leader I promised myself I would be
letting all pursue their happiness as
they see fit that's a pretty good
description of Anarchy peasants welcome
to the Future let your voice be heard
for the first time it's a trick we think
she is a witch it doesn't even look like
me and they do what with it line up to
spit in its face the hair's good no it's
not your eyes are wrong they're the
wrong blue yours are more crystalline
out there millions of hearts boiling
with hate you risk the legitimacy of
your rule an uprising is building
they're burning towns down what would
you do you're the empress you say we're
all going beaver hunting you're the
worst leader imaginable spoken like
someone who's ever seen the joy and
camaraderie engendered by beaver hunting
here is a book on the science of
marriage a couple must stay balanced as
we throw balls at you I have you always
sorry
happy wife happy life where's your
loyalty to us you have one job and that
is to preserve the line family not
enjoying this conversation shall I dance
around a bit as we do it so it's more
pleasing for you
they hate me
of course they love me so it's hard to
relate nothing you've done has worked
you are a failure
risking my rule on an idea stupid idea a
beautiful idea trying to lead a people
out of a swamp of hundreds of years is
hard I will win I am me I will pull this
off your famous confidence remains
intact
taste this oh delicious when Paul was
born your placenta is placed in a barrel
of the finest vodka I just drank My
Placenta sweet and strong like you so
little yeasty though
if you want to be part of what we're
doing you need to show us that you're
committed to our vision
can you hear me
I need you to listen to me because I
want to tell you something that a friend
once told me
you said you can hide but you can't run
you wanted me to know that hurt will
follow you it follows you wherever you
go
he was right
[Music]
only thing I know that will leave you
this
people you still have left
just don't do what I did
don't rhyme
I said if he would Dwayne before he died
your second chance dad she's right
Morgan
Rick it gave you this gun for a reason
use it
as you can see it's a really great
neighborhood oh yeah it's a great one
this has great phones
[Music]
I'm sorry would you excuse me what the
hell happened hit and run I'm never
going to that Walmart again
[Music]
[Applause]
what did you while mommy was here but
ain't happening anymore
I told you I'm a private investigator
now
you're just gonna have to hustle I need
a Hustle No to hustle this is the time
peg you're a phoenix baby I know
what are you supposed to be a real Pi
what do you plan at I'm not hiring I'm a
natural detective you need me and I need
this job be here Monday morning at 9am I
don't get up before 11. when I had money
we all had money from dealing drugs
it was a little pot maybe some hash
there was cocaine well that was much
later and I did it I didn't sell it oh
wow okay
good comes from bad but I need that
thing that I've always missed you got
some oxy
no I'm on methadone crepe
things
to change that fast
I worry that the next time I come out
here is going to be for my sister's
funeral fire in the hole
you're at the point of no return
go put this thing could put us on the
map
what what are you looking ah get out of
here
[Music]
how many uncles you got five
five it feels like 50 most of the time
though let's go guys we don't have all
day
my dad left when I was little so all my
uncles are always around and they're
super protective of my mom and me
what's that feel like mostly it's like
being inside a cloud of bees except the
bees are always cussing and punching at
each other
okay
you guys have to understand that your
influence on him is Meaningful but he
needs to make decisions on his own that
doesn't make sense if you want a thing
speak up so you're smart today I'm smart
every day your t-shirt's on backwards
what
it's a v-neck what is wrong with you I
thought it was from Europe
I have way too many opinions coming at
me once
do I go to college higher education is
the key do I join the military that's
what I do do I start working it should
be contributing to the family whatever
your path is man that's your path that
poem sucked
what happened with that girl you like
Whose advice did you take oh I had a lot
of really good options the way you
connect with someone is through communal
crying did you think about wearing
cologne I look sick as hell yeah you do
which Uncle did this because this can't
be all you y'all don't like it she's
gonna think you're a divorced magician
foreign
[Music]
it's that time of year the Gonzalez
family Barbecue we learned to cook
Mexican food like me you'll never be
single you can single my whole life by
choice
my family is crazy
I do like that your family is great you
got six people in this house give a damn
about what happens to you that must suck
let me warn you right now almost all of
these are intimacy related said Uncle
roley said Uncle Mike said Uncle Ryan
said Uncle Jay said don't go to any of
your uncles about anything intimacy
related ever for the rest of your life
well Scott her all worked up
us
oh
all right
why couldn't you be my uncle
firmly
[Music]
do you know anything about this murder
I've heard things
Tommy Lee Royce how do
it's complicated but is I mean Dad can't
you suck yourself it is
everything I've ever done is in the best
interests they've been in a fight
several
can you get me some more moderation is
the thing
nothing I've got a job for you he's part
of it keep on doing what you're doing
please mind me on to me
they found a body
come on wakey wakey you planted it he's
using you and you're letting him send
him on his way if it didn't bother
something to work
it's him that's done it
okay family movie night guys oh wow what
Will's getting a divorce so call him we
literally haven't spoken to each other
in years call him that's what friends do
hey how are you
I'm actually the brewmaster at my own
bar now congratulations you still got
that uh family of yours you want to see
a photo
wow there they are cool
what are you up to
this one so lunch no brunch no I don't
have time for this can't be friends with
a girl there's lots of famous men and
women friends Laura Dern and Sam Neal in
Jurassic Park
[Applause]
you're a friendship with Will
not built for this phase of
them this is how a woman experiences a
midlife crisis there's a couple of
teenage girls your whole thing is so
weird and destructive
I don't like feeling like the second
most important man in your life
it's embarrassing being a mess in front
of you and Will's a much bigger mess
than I am
for you to end up having you idiot well
I am happy I've never been happier in my
life
send me the invoice
break out of your box do a little nose
candy with us
did they have some pay back in the day
just like a mild horse tranquilizer it's
a horse foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
in my defense
I thought it was cocaine
and just so I'm clear that's your
defense
the defense rests
[Applause]
[Music]
he made his choice
you sound like you've given up on easy
you haven't you can run for a long time
half our brothers are murdered only
thing you can trust you to do
the rest you killed too
just believe in me a little longer I'm
about to take this club to Heights it's
never seen
get your brother to stop he doesn't
listen to me you convince him we are in
a war we have to win but there's no way
to defeat the Suns without Bloodshed
easy is gonna get us all hurt our
enemies have finally shown some life
I'm not leaving until someone dies
[Music]
one of our brothers has been working
with the feds we have a rat they came to
my house and threatened my family we're
done
you're setting yourself up to get
crucified
[Music]
FX is the final season premieres May
24th on FX stream on Hulu
you know people love this it's good for
you right but this one looks like he's
giving me the thumbs up
is there a Jim Wang here
well this is Wayne Chang waitan he's a
new student and he's Chinese like you
he's gonna tag along to all of your
classes
accept math
he's way ahead of you in math I just
want to be a regular guy who does
regular stuff you made a new friend
I just thought this year was gonna be
different
foreign
I may be able to help
[Music]
what's going on I'm not from this world
I need your help with my quest to stop
the uprising
the gate between Earth and Heaven is
opening okay
you must stop it or everyone will perish
the fate of Your World hangs in the
balance I don't really see how I fit
into this whole thing from my guide we
thought it was something a little bit
cooler than guide servant yeah I know
you're right guys better
[Music]
it will be difficult and dangerous look
at the hero what if I'm not though
faith is not decided up there but down
here
so freaking unbelievable
everything is more connected than you
think
yay
[Music]
what was the plan to kill all of you and
then to leave and now with all our guns
out I'll manage
you're the fastest 65 year old white guy
on the planet I guess I'm done
you are officially retired how are you
gonna spend your golden years huh
so I missed you
missed you I'm tired I'm going to meet
my wife back what's going to stop us 15
year old divorce papers she doesn't love
you anymore
can I talk to you for a minute
we're going to lose an operative
code names Panda I'm retired
we've been extract Panda grab the wmd
zip on now
okay Dollar in the swear jar I remember
the wmd's tour so follow me or get out
of my way
she clearly has daddy issues
she treats me like a child alcohol
cigarettes and the garish lipstick
that's not lipstick oh my gosh vibrating
my God kill me now take your daughter to
work day is going well
Emma I'm okay just take him out
lean up
what
I've learned a ton from working with my
dad
how he leads the team how he keeps his
cool how to Slit a man's throat
vertically so he bleeds out faster
they got more issues than Sports
illustrate
now
that was on me this is totally
ah
you should end the marriage before you
do you think I'm a virgin well let me
think what I want to think oh my God I'm
28.
by the power vested in me I pronounce
you husband and wife
[Music]
are you okay I just had the dream again
uh-oh our greatest fear sending a
brother off to the land of the beckies I
uh I joined a dating house she about to
be out here in these streets oh yeah in
these highly selective no one under 511
street so did you find a winner
oh God just swipe left no throw my phone
in the toilet now that Ola is back out
there I need to be like out there out
there
it's a whole new with me I want to
change the subject we have an
understanding you need a tight little
dress you can show off that booty he
won't be able to say no
well damn
time to get back over
I made a lot of decisions that I wasn't
always happy with and it gave me the hot
tea on you three life is too short for
what ifs and there are no accidents is
it I say go for it
who's the boss I'm the boss who's the
boss I'm the boss
strong independent women
[Music]